un año después de su reelección Emanuel
macún busca recuperarse de la crisis
social y política en la cual está
asumido el país su tasa de popularidad
ha bajado en las últimas semanas con
solo el 26% de franceses satisfechos con
su trabajo y un 47% muy insatisfechos se
debe en gran parte a la adopción por
decreto y sin voto de la asamblea
nacional de la muy popular reforma de
las pensiones parte de los franceses
acusa A Emmanuel macu de gobernar de
manera autoritaria y de estar
desconectado de la sociedad
hoy tenemos la impresión de estar ante
un gobierno sordo que no está en
absoluto por la comunicación tenemos la
impresión de que Manuel macron no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver con lo que
ocurre en su propio país
si su gobierno Ha logrado bajar la tasa
de desempleo y ha empezado a
reindustrializar el país estos efectos
no se sienten la inflación sigue cinco
por ciento y el poder adquisitivo se ve
muy afectado a pesar de las ayudas del
gobierno finalmente el jefe de estado no
logra imponerse como intermediario en la
escena internacional sus intentos de
dialogar con los mandatarios Ruso y
chino para encontrar una solución a la
guerra en Ucrania no han dado frutos
recientemente también fue criticado por
sus declaraciones sobre Taiwán y su
llamado a ser independiente de Estados
Unidos sobre esta cuestión ahora el
mandatario quiere restablecer el diálogo
con los franceses
se está expresando esta cólera no
esperaba otra cosa pero no me impedirá
seguir moviéndome por el país porque
tenemos que seguir actuando y avanzando
100 días para relanzar su mandato que
debería centrarse en la transición
ecológica el jefe de estado buscará
adoptar nuevas reformas pero sin mayoría
en la asamblea nacional y Con un fuerte
descontento social los tres años que le
quedan pueden ser desafiantes